i agree he comes over to my house right
and he's like
oh um oh no which uh
which bidet thing do i press right and
and i was like you press the one that
like says uh
yeah has an arsenal yeah that's right
and he's like i've been pressing all of
them
i'm like what do you mean you impressed
all of them
he's like he's like oh i thought it was
like a course
yeah like of course like a bidet course
three course meal like what do you mean
he's like yeah because one of them's
like hard one of them soft and then one
of them does like a different area
cleaning the ass cheeks i mean he's
pressing like the the
bidet and then pressing the ass cleaning
the vagina one as well yeah i didn't
know that was a vagina one
i thought the picture looked like it
splashes your butt yeah yeah so i
thought it was like one is for the
inside and the one for is the soft
inside after you wipe once
and then the third one is cleaning your
ass cheeks in case you got poop all over
your eyes
i'll violin all your shits
no i don't do it anymore and now that
connor told me that it wasn't a
uh that's the reason why dad's on the
toilet because he's having a three
course
yeah literally
he's eating a three i've never heard us
mention a course before ever about meals
or anything he's never been interested
in it but suddenly bidet courses take
courses and i'm like what did you get
we're like a tux today
it's like let me see the menu let me see
your menu oh we go we've got four
courses today
like that's what you you saw three and
you're like i must be of course yes yeah
how would i know it's in japanese on the
screen here's the thing and there's one
the one that says oshiri is the one for
your butt yeah that's all you need to
press
stop obviously
did it it was just such a funny thing
she was just like i just she was so
wholesome
[Laughter]
so yeah like is the bidet one of your
favorite things about japan
oh and the bathroom the the uh the hot
tub i mean not the hot tub hot tub the
tub
the tub becomes hot
i remember emily said that you take a
bath every day yeah and now i'm like
watching netflix in it
dude it's the best it's the [ __ ] bad
and i got drinking
feeling like a king it's very nice it's
very interesting because in america you
don't want to take a bath because you
shower in the same bath right so it gets
nasty and then you're sharing it
every single bath i've ever been in
someone's house in the u.s looks vile
yeah yeah yeah yeah like it looks
disgusting yeah yeah but that's because
they don't use it yeah it's just a place
to stay yeah and people people don't
wash their bathtubs much in the us right
[Laughter]
yeah asian mom is like did you did your
family take baths or they're just
cleaning it just for the oh okay
well yeah because it looks nasty but
yeah but there's still like scuffs that
you can't like remove ever yeah yeah
and you're like you're like looking at
it while you're showering you're like
yeah
in the uk we had like a bath like
separate they had like no shower
anything oh really yeah did you clean
the balls no my mom did
oh no no i just made like in general
yeah no i didn't until i came to japan
yeah yeah yeah i was like why is it like
what i feel like crust on my back
grease build up yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so you gotta like you gotta
clean it everything yeah i know james
people clean it every time
they hear a quick scrub right normally
yeah yeah my mom used that at home used
to like do a quick scrub of it and then
fill the bath i do like every like two
three weeks if i'm feeling you know
until i notice something yeah yeah when
i feel something that i'm like all right
you put your fingers yeah because you
can put your finger against it and it
isn't like smooth yeah yeah and then you
got to clean it sure you're here it's
not anything bad you can't see anything
yeah yeah yeah well sometimes you just
got to clean up the bathroom period
right because unfortunately you just
gunk up the best i don't know why you'd
ever want to yeah i agree like you just
can't it's amazing like i just you know
the japanese showers are like wet oh
okay okay
you can put stuff on the floor in
america if you put something on the
floor you might damage your house yeah
yeah like all the all the like the mist
and stuff stays in the back yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so you don't have like the molds yeah
you say you don't have like the mold
build up sometimes yeah yeah yeah that
is really good yeah i don't fill in the
bath it's amazing you can choose the
temperature and the level and it talks
to you and the time as well like you can
like set that [ __ ] yeah like you fill it
up at 6 a.m i just don't understand why
we don't have that in like the uk or the
us like why would not enough people take
bars i guess
they would if you had a oh oh you're
getting up at 6 50 a.m you want to be
set for that i'm saying i'm saying like
bidets why is that not normalized
worldwide it's catching up on america
it's becoming
but
it's just like i think in america just
quick quick quick look like yeah take
your final shower get out but like my
baths aren't that long like you can you
know i i just like the fact that you
could stand on the the floor and be like
oh this is fine yeah
you step on the floor in the in america
you're like oh like everything's wet
yeah everything's wet yeah yeah yeah
it's not good
yeah cause like i remember like the
absolute state of like british toilets
right i remember i go to like one public
restroom and like you know this was just
like the day that i landed as well
and like this thing like forget not
having a big day this didn't even have a
toilet seat
[ __ ] you're not right not even late huh
is she i just i just went in and i was
like i was expecting at least a toilet
seat and they just like oh my gosh oh my
god this is the most depressing sight
i've ever seen oh my god
basically
you told me before that like because
like because
you are so happy with the bidets because
before you like wipe so hard that you
like you start
well in america i like to do this thing
i get made fun of i don't know why
but i do wet dry wet dry like i put my
toilet paper in in the
in the the sink to make it a little bit
wet so i'll get the wet to pick up the
poop and then dry to to clean it and i
go back to wet and i go back to dry
that's a lot you know that's a lot yeah
no what are you doing the course meal
yeah you were doing that before yeah i
would like
[Laughter]
i've definitely never heard of that
that's
did you just figure that out yourself
pixel poop and then the dryer cleans it
so wait how did you like like
you know damaged wipes have you ever
used wet wipes i guess i guess if you
wipe too much on cheap toilet paper or
something yeah yeah and your [ __ ]
stinks it's not bleeding but it stinks
that means it's coming something is
definitely going wrong it usually means
yeah it's amazing have you ever used wet
wipes on your iceland if you're like
wetting the [ __ ] i read online that
red white wipes is bad for your [ __ ]
appreciate
this is the first i'm hearing that's bad
for your ass yeah why is it bad for your
[ __ ] i i don't know i googled it
alcohol one well no but there's weight
wipes that don't have alcohol in them
yeah like you got like the baby wipes
right which is literally no it's just
google i think everything's bad so
that's true oh happiness that's bad
actually that's true yeah oh you have
depression crippling depression you're
sad forever now i mean i'm sure i'm sure
like baby wipes right like wet baby
wipes yeah yeah yeah we'll be all right
yeah i mean that one it seems more
effective than having to like having
like a three course
could you reach the sink from the toilet
in your previous part perhaps yeah most
of the time i was gonna say because like
are you are you pre-working well the
things that you're right here so you're
just okay so i was gonna say i was
wondering if you're like pre-wetting a
bunch and then going
well and sometimes when i go to a
friend's house i'm like oh dang there's
things like far away
so what do you do so what do you do i'll
pretty wet like a bunch not a bunch not
a bunch maybe like one or two and then
like what if you need more
well if my [ __ ] is like
like almost clean but not completely
clean i'll like waddle over
and waddle back
your friends are never inviting you
thank god you don't do i have a clean
[ __ ] i don't know what to tell you
say bro give me bring me some
toilet paper
my ass stinks